vamos con el problema 77 en el problema
77 nos dice que el ingreso de la señora
smith fue 20% más para 1991 que para
1990 déjame escribirlo así el ingreso de
1991 de la señora smith fue 1.2 veces el
ingreso de 1990 sale porque porque si el
ingreso de 1990 fue esta cantidad punto
dos veces eso es el 20% entonces si el
de 1991 fue 20 por ciento más entonces
sería esta cantidad la cantidad más
punto dos veces la cantidad vale bueno
lo que nos piden determinar es cuál fue
el ingreso en 1991 en 1991 vamos a ver
qué información nos dan en el inciso 1
nos dice que el ingreso de la señora
smith en los primeros 6 meses de 1990
fue de 17.500 dólares me imagino
y en los segundos seis meses o sea en el
segundo semestre fue 20000
20.000 estos son en los semestres de
1990 entonces básicamente nos están
dando el ingreso de 1990 si el ingreso
de 1990 es igual a la suma de estos dos
ingresos que sería 37 mil 500 y entonces
para determinar el ingreso de 1991
podríamos simplemente multiplicar por
1.2 entonces este insisto es suficiente
para responder la pregunta vamos a ver
qué dice el inciso 2 dice que dice que
la señora smith tuvo un ingreso en 1991
7500 dólares más que el de 1990 o sea
nos está diciendo que el ingreso de 1991
fue igual al ingreso de 1990 más 7500
7500 y esto también nos permite
determinar el valor verdad porque ahora
tenemos esta ecuación de acá esta
ecuación de acá son dos ecuaciones con
las cuales bueno podemos resolverlas
porque tienen dos incógnitas son
lineales y entonces pues juntando esta
con esta podemos resolver este las dos
ecuaciones y obtener el valor del
ingreso en 1991 no lo voy a hacer pero
te lo dejo de tarea para cuando tengas
un ratito libre para que veas que sí es
cierto vale bueno entonces esta de acá
también es suficiente juntando la con la
hipótesis original entonces aquí la
respuesta sería de de muy bien vamos
ahora al problema 78 voy a usar este
color azul que casi nunca lo uso para
los problemas aquí tenemos que hacer un
dibujo en los cuales tenemos pues hay un
plano cartesiano tenemos los dos ejes
tenemos aquí el eje y tenemos el eje x y
nos pone en una recta déjame poner la
recta nos pone en esta recta de ahí nos
marcan algunos puntos por aquí está el
punto p por acá está el punto q
para este punto que luego marcan este
segmento más o menos y este segmento y
este punto de intersección es el punto r
déjame a ver si no me falta nada me
faltan estas coordenadas la coma ve
estas de acá se coma d
y creo que es todo sí ok entonces
tenemos este dibujo en el problema 78 y
el problema nos dice en la figura los
segmentos pr y qr son ambos paralelos a
alguno de los ejes ok este es paralelo
al eje y este es paralelo al eje x muy
bien y la pregunta es cuál es la razón
de la longitud de qr a pr
entonces nos piden por la longitud r / p
r
muy bien entonces básicamente lo que nos
están preguntando aquí es la pendiente
de esta recta verdad tenemos q r entre
pr que es el incremento vertical entre
el incremento horizontal vale entonces
pues queremos determinar esta razón de
acá vamos a ver qué información nos dan
o sabes que mejor aún vamos a ver que
necesitaríamos para encontrar esto de
aquí cuánto sería la longitud de qr
bueno pues la longitud de qr es tomar
este puntito de acá este puntito de acá
y restarle este puntito de acá sería de
menos b entonces q r
q r es igual a de menos b sale y bueno
qué sucede con con pr pr ahora sería
tomar esta longitud verdad y eso quiere
decir hace que es esta coordenada de x
verdad hace restarle a
entonces ahora pr déjame ponerle br br
es igual hace menos
entonces para determinar esta razón qr
entre pr simplemente debemos dividir de
menos b en 13 menos a c menos a ok
entonces esto es lo que queremos
determinar vamos a ver que nos dan la
información en el inciso 1 nos dicen que
se es igual a 3 y de es igual a 4 que es
igual a 3 y de es igual a 4 o sea nos
dan las coordenadas de este punto de acá
bueno pues nada más teniendo estas
coordenadas no podemos encontrar este
valor porque simplemente son dos números
de los cuatro que necesitamos entonces
este por sí mismo no funciona y en el 2
lo que nos dan es a pues justo las otras
dos coordenadas a es igual a menos 2
y ve es igual a menos 1 b igual a menos
1 este por sí mismo otra vez no nos
permite concluir nada acerca de esta
expresión porque nos faltaría
información acerca de ese y de d
pero si juntamos la información de los
dos incisos entonces tenemos todas las
variables que necesitamos abs y de iu y
entonces pues podemos calcular esta
pendiente
vamos a hacerlo nada más para para no
dejarlo así tan abandonado nos quedaría
4 menos menos 1 o sea 5 dividido en 13 o
sea 3 menos y menos -2 3 + 2 que sería 5
y entonces la pendiente sería igual a 1
sale bueno entonces cada uno de estos
por separado no funciona pero si
juntamos los dos sí y entonces la
respuesta sería c muy bien vayamos ahora
al problema 79
el problema 79 lo voy a hacer en color
naranja problema 79 79 muy bien dice en
una carretera recta el coche xy el coche
ya están viajando a un ritmo constante
pero diferente esta constante me imagino
para cada carro pero diferente entre
cada uno de los carros ok
nos dice si el coche uno ahorita está
una milla adelante del coche 2 déjame
llamarles mejor el coche x y el coche y
al entonces si el coche x está una milla
adelante que le voy a poner una milla
adelante del coche y en cuántos minutos
el coche x va a estar dos millas
adelante del coche y entonces queremos
saber
el tiempo para que para que el coche x
para que x esté
a dos millas de el coche y sale
bueno pues o sea hay varias formas en
las cuales vamos a poder resolver esto
verdad a lo mejor si nos dan que
empezaron en un mismo lugar y esta
situación sucedió en 10 minutos pues
entonces podamos resolverlo en efecto si
sabemos eso y en diez minutos el coche x
se adelantó una milla entonces en otros
diez minutos se va a adelantar otra
milla entonces esa sería una forma de
poder responder esto pero vamos a ver
qué que nos dan de información inciso 1
en el inciso 1 nos dicen que el coche x
está viajando a 50 millas por hora y x
viaja a 50 millas por hora y que el
coche y viaja a 40 millas por hora que
viaja a 40 millas millas por hora pues
esta información está súper buena verdad
si el coche x viaja a 50 millas por hora
y el coche llega a 40 millas por hora
entonces relativamente el coche x viaja
a 10 millas por hora con respecto al
coche
este viaja 50 este a 40 entonces este va
a 10 millas más rápido entonces x le voy
a poner así con respecto a iu
tiene una velocidad tiene una velocidad
de 10 millas 10 millas por hora entonces
cuánto tiempo tardará el coche x en
adelantarse otra milla más pues ya
podemos responderlo verdad tenemos que
velocidad velocidad es igual a distancia
entre tiempo lo que nos dan ahorita es
velocidad y distancia entonces lo que
queremos es determinar tiempo tiempo es
igual a distancia entre velocidad la
distancia que queremos que se recorra es
de una milla verdad que recorre a una
milla adicional ya le lleva una de
ventaja falta otra entonces sería igual
a una milla dividido entre la velocidad
que es esta velocidad relativa diez
millas por hora
aquí millas se cancela con millas
dividir entre una división de horas es
que horas sube entonces nos queda un
décimo de hora y eso en minutos esos
minutos es igual
pues un décimo de horas son seis minutos
seis minutos entonces tardará seis
minutos en adelantarse otra milla vale
ahora vamos a ver qué dice el inciso 2
en el inciso 2 nos dice que hace 3
minutos
hace tres minutos hace 3 minutos el
coche x estaba media milla adelante del
entonces x media milla
adelante de adelante de
de ok entonces no sé a lo mejor hace
tres minutos poder pues por aquí estaba
x en este punto x prima por acá esta
valle en este punto y prima pero estoy
aquí pues también es información
importante verdad si hace tres minutos x
estaba a media milla como tienen
velocidad constante entonces pues eso
quiere decir que cada tres minutos x se
le adelanta media milla allí sale porque
en esos tres minutos que pasaron de
media milla de diferencia media milla
pasó a una milla entonces pues podemos
saber que en otros tres minutos pues se
va a adelantar otra media milla y en
otros tres minutos se va a adelantar
otra media milla entonces para que esté
a dos millas necesita una milla
adicional que sabemos que toma seis
minutos seis minutos sale otra vez en
tres minutos se adelantó media milla en
seis minutos se va a adelantar la milla
adicional que necesita